je suis allé voir France Angleterre au
Qatar
je peux vous dire
je me suis chié dessus
sans jouer les mecs
et je suis allé voir aussi jolie je mens
pas
je
je suis allé voir
les gros titres argent je suis allé voir
Argentine Pays-Bas
de 2 Bam Bam Bam j'étais avec un ami
j'embrasse la vie très proche j'avais
parié avec lui je lui ai dit parce que à
deux il me dit les Pays-Bas ont gagné
par l'Argentine va gagner depuis le
début tout ce que je dis sur la Coupe du
Monde c'est vrai j'ai dit que la France
elle est de championne du monde j'ai dit
le Maroc il va être ton demi-finale
alors vous allez voir voilà je suis très
très content
la France va être championne du monde
les mecs et la finale ça va être France
Argentine Croatie
la Croatie et bam bam et si Basic et
thomasique et clap bonjour
c'est tout les gars
je vous le dis je vous le dis zéro
chance que le Maroc passe alors je suis
fou mais les mecs la France je vous dis
en fait la France et j'ai vu le match la
France ils ont un truc ils ont tellement
des individualités incroyables c'est dès
qu'ils sont en attaque tu sais qui
peuvent marquer et contrôle Angleterre
l'Angleterre ils ont fait un match de
foot on va pas se mentir les Anglais
même moi ils m'ont impressionné j'aurais
dit eh côte de Queen
mais les Français à chaque fois qu'il y
a une action tu sens que ça peut taper
regardez et je pense et je pense ça va
être le match de Killian mercredi je
pense vraiment ça va être il va aimer le
Maroc demi-finale c'est le Maroc va
terminer troisième le match l'Argentine
après
Coupe du monde je l'ai dit depuis le
début je l'ai dit ou pas dis la vérité
vous l'avez dit depuis le début a perdu
beaucoup d'argent toi à cause de moi non
mais je vous le dis et là-bas alors et
je vais vous dire par contre je suis
allé là-bas les mecs c'est pas Paris
c'est propre à les mecs mais c'est un
truc de ouf
le rat c'était moi je vous le dis non
mais ça décoller non mais les mecs c'est
un truc de ouf ça veut dire c'est à
Paris tu sais que tu peux croiser un rat
tout le moment ou dans un lieu de vie tu
vois là-bas mais quel rat dis la-bas
[Rires]
je n'ai jamais vu ça on ne mangerait par
terre dehors j'ai mangé par terre j'ai
mangé par terre j'ai mangé par terre non
non franchement ah oui match incroyable
l'équipe de France incroyable et voilà
je vous dis il y a une très bonne
ambiance je sens bien et Giroud encore
une fois incroyable Olivier toujours
moins fort j'aime et c'est vrai que là
et il y avait
ils avaient dit que c'est les boycotter
la Coupe du monde
les audiences n'ont jamais été aussi
alors
je vais vous dire la vérité j'en avais
deux je vous dis j'en ai donné une à mon
fils vraiment et le deuxième cadeau
arrive il sera là dans quelques minutes
je regarde est-ce que le cadeau arrive
est-ce que le cadeau arrive
il arrive de ses propres moyens
d'accord le cadeau arrive dans quelques
instants les chéris vous allez voir très
très beau cadeau c'est la dernière
semaine avant Noël on joue c'est bientôt
Noël les cadeaux oui pour préparer et
oui c'est bientôt Noël les chéris et
donc c'est notre dernière semaine après
on est obligé pour des questions
d'argent je le dis moi j'aurais bien
aimé j'aurais bien rester je serais
resté moins Noël je rêvais j'ai toujours
rêvé de faire une émission le jour de
l'an et le jour de Noël vraiment pour
elle pour être avec vous franchement je
fais jamais des trucs de ouf le jour de
l'an l'année dernière j'ai mangé un
savane de papy Brossard
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
connaissez Del Piero
tu joues avec ma thérapie
[Musique]
j'ai joué un autre joueur qui joue avec
Christiane Viry ah oui c'est très gros
joueur d'accord
il y avait Ronaldo est parti parce que
comme ils sont perdus ils jouaient il
est parti on s'est croisé avec moi
non non il y avait des anciens joueurs
il y avait tout le monde tous les matins
rendez-vous avec tout le monde c'est bon
ça incroyable
et ouais vous savez comment on appelait
là-bas ou pas deux le roi et le
professeur
il dit la vérité tu veux que j'appelle
qui tu veux que j'appelle qui voulait
que j'appelle qui appelle la serre ah
oui
pas du tout
tu es con ou quoi tu es là-bas j'aurais
bien aimé non non mais franchement vas-y
ah ben non alors il sait que Loïc il
faut
vous dire
[Rires]
non laissez-le laissez-le il est malade
allô mon Loïc ouais je suis avec Cyril
là tu sais on fait un truc le soir là
c'est clair et tout avec des gens sur la
télé et tu connais pas regardé c'est
sympa
apparemment vous avez été faire du
paddle au Qatar et c'est quoi le surnom
de Cyril là-bas au Qatar comment
l'appeler là-bas
elle professeur
les gars se battaient pour jouer avec
moi se battez j'appelle mon fils il a
envoyé du coup là-bas tu dis
numéro 1
[Applaudissements]